hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to speak
in nine languages now speaking
lots of languages makes me a polyglot
remember if you enjoy my videos please
subscribe
click on the bell for notifications and
if you follow me on apple
podcast please leave a review
so for much of my life i never heard the
word polyglot polyglot meaning someone
who speaks many languages it's from
the greek many tongues uh to me it was a
linguist
in fact i wrote my book about 15 years
ago
called the way of the linguist but now
the word polyglot has become established
more and more
there's more and more people putting out
videos where they speak
five ten fifteen languages um
and people enjoy doing that people enjoy
watching them
so i have done the same i've done so in
the past on occasion
uh and i think the important thing is
that
we can learn not only one additional
language we can
learn quite a few additional languages
as long as we are motivated
we are curious we are interested we put
in the time
and hopefully my video will encourage
people
to learn more languages so here you go
[Music]
[Music]
is